you
but it's very interesting to hear this
reaction talked about as a work in
progress 30 that there is a current
situation where you're dealing with CM
there is an eventual position where
perhaps you can go back to ch because
when when I think they're talked about
normally it's as if they are things that
have been given the to the community and
this is the heck reaction this is the
negotiation this is Suzuki reaction and
they are to be used and one doesn't
think about their further development
but of course they are they are
development of each other and there is
it there is a continuation yeah I think
that's our ambition and our eventual
goal is to be able to hook together any
any order to any two organic groups and
we believe that our are you know we have
covered a little more than halfway
through towards this goal but in each
case as I said eventually it would be
very nice to replace memo with hydrogen
but to what extent we can do is our
remaining question
you